30 millions d'amis une première pierre
desproges on a dit que vous aviez un
chien les animaux extraordinaires de
pierre desproges avec naf native match
4-6 ont sciemment jour de graines spa
chaîne de chasse qui acteurs des poules
des lapins mi-lourds le lapin boxeur
géants sont joséphine la chronique
savante
cette poule est la mère des ses chiens
en fait c'est simple c'est la merde aux
petits scène tels qu'ils les approuvent
et qui les a élevés
vous avez vu donc ce chien prépetit elle
résulte est tout petit il a été
abandonné par la mère qui était une
espagnole et qui est partie d'ailleurs
qu'un chanteur espagnol et qui a laissé
tomber ses quatre petits et c'est cette
poule c'est adorable petite bête qui les
a recueillis se sont elles ce sont des
chiens complètement en poule et si je
pouvais sommaires ainsi qu'ils ne
mangent que comme le pousse à la voyez
vous si j'ai le dos les parterres non
elle ne préfère le blé dans la bouche
directement c'est quand même qu'elle a
gardé quelque chose du chien ce meuble
c'est son atavisme le cas d'un tirage il
a alors qu'une foule devrait carrément
aux plantes et voyez-vous de lebbeke
et quand un mec c'est un peu mou ce don
qui mangent du grain et sa préférence le
soir ils vont dans le sens large que je
croyais quand même si sa couche comme
les poules se couche à 80 milles et
l'hiver et vers 19h le était couchée 9,9
et ile maurice rendre tous les cinq dans
le poulailler
et puis c'est le chant du coq chien qui
les réveille le lendemain matin il ne
compte pas se tient à préciser
on a beaucoup fabulé là-dessus aucun
chien détail est capable de pondre en
revanche jolie leur pouce des plus
mauvais au derrière
celui ci un vieux manteau de laine qui
cache bien ses plumes c'est un set à
chaque est qui et qui sortait d'un gros
pouce à un bon gros poussin taureauvous
synthois il jouera vraiment aller parce
que beaucoup chien c'est l'animal
coiffure et le chien modérément le chien
c'est le chien c'est un pour moi c'est
qu'une vague relations ce soit l'amour
en revanche l'animal chère à mon coeur
c'est le cochon je crois vraiment en
réalité qu'est le le cochon est la plus
noble conquête de l'homme avec la femme
la face surtout le cochon à 6 ils
voulaient me suivre dans ma porcherie ce
que vous montrez moi oui c'est pour
souvent jeune et je vais à 350 coach
nîmois peu près jamais porcherie on va y
aller
alors là vous avez je le dis en toute
modestie une des plus belles collections
de que font du monde et s'il ya
certaines pièces qui datent tous deux
mois qui ont toutes trois siècles d'âge
certaines sont en or massif celle ci est
en platine ont parmi celles ci
je tiens tout particulièrement à ces
cochons qui sont tous les quatre qui
appartiennent tous les quatre à la
grande famille des cochons de béatrice
potter la grande dessinatrice anglaise
qui m'en a fait cadeau au cours d'un
après-midi que je passais avec elle dans
une meule dans un an dans une auberge
des campagnes britannique
à
m
et
bon par ailleurs vous avez ici des
cochons noble tous de noble extraction
qui ont énormément souffert de la
révolution française
c'était très dur pour ça non mais ça ça
ne s'écrit [ __ ] quant à cette pièce
que voici
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
étonnant il s'agit d' un goret qui me
vient de hollande ça public aurait sont
rares le long des digues ce qui crée de
temps sa valeur est alors chose
étonnante encore plus c'est que dans ce
cochon qui me vient d'amsterdam
quand on met une pièce de monnaie dedans
voyez-vous dans le port d'amsterdam ya
des marins qui chantent
pardon pardon c'est moi c'est pas cuit 1
ce lapin c'est un ou c'est moi j'aime
bien les bêtes en général fait un tabac
de chez moi là vous avez un lapin à côté
d'un chien de chasse est inscrite
étonnant c'est que voyez l'attitude du
chien de chasse quand il est pas dans la
nature par rapport à la pâte c'est
complètement différent j'ai plutôt
tendance à sauver et ce lapin quand on
le laisse avec le chien il se met sur
son petit derrière et ils filent des
gifles aux chiens c'est pour ça mais là
je suis obligé de tenir
voyez vous l'attitude d'un chêne chasse
en face d'un lapin dans un appartement
c'est très curieux pour faire écouter
aurait pas trop s'attarder sur le lapin
parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment si les cochons mais placé borné
pour le les choses de la vie
mais là comme une qualité qui est
exceptionnel chez les grenouilles c'est
que fifine ses comptes et je vais vous
l'avez dressa compte elle ses comptes et
elle sait faire des opérations simples
évidemment vous n'êtes pas de racine
carrée parce que la paix n'a pas encore
des jeunes et donc elle un petit peu
faibles d'esprit mais enfin un peu comme
on va essayer d'avoir repris alors c'est
vrai qu'on est fini on va compliquer un
peu voir trois de fifine 3 et 2 oui ça
aussi mais on va compliquer un peu alors
si c'est un bon six mois-un an plus tôt
ah ça c'est difficile c'est fini c'est
une soustraction six mois-un l'imposent
eater
oui de la bd vous pouvez re poser la
question plus lentement alors le 6 - 1
six mois-un fifine
c'est bien parce que l'effort ton
histoire de france voulait qu'elle vous
donne la date de la date de la bataille
de marignan la date de la bataille de
marignan fifine la date de la bataille
de marignan aller